wollt ihr wissen wie maultaschen gemacht
habe zuerst einmal herzlich willkommen
in meiner toten meeres ich mache heute
mit drei verschiedene maultaschen einmal
mit nach fleisch füllung einmal mit
frischkäse fülle und einmal mit einer
kartoffel füllung und ich muss euch
unbedingt jetzt noch sagen woher die
maultaschen kommen weil mein mann das
unbedingt hören wollte und zwar sind
maultaschen aus dem schwabenland und
damit man in waschechter türkischer
schlafe ich muss ich den maultaschen
natürlich immer selber machen bei uns
gibt es nicht aus der tüte und nicht aus
der frische packung sondern selbst
gemacht und die maultaschen sind ja auch
schnell selbst gemacht und wie das
funktioniert zeigt euch jetzt in der
küche also das heißt eigentlich es muss
jetzt sagen wir sind ja ich keine es
heißt einen raschen des landes sondern
normalerweise sagen wir schwaben und zu
herzen und herrgott scheiße daher ich
machen untertitel jetzt der per kopf
es kommt daher an karfreitag durften die
schwaben ja kein fleisch essen
nico fisch und dann was haben wir
gemacht wir haben das fleisch einfach in
diese zeit so verpackt dass man das
nicht sehen
deswegen herrgotts bescheid genau diese
ich werde jetzt zeigen wie man eine
portion tag macht und zwar wird die aus
drei eiern hergestellt und es heißt so
pi mal daumen dass das für zwei bis drei
personen reicht und ich zeige ich jetzt
einfach mal die zutaten ihr braucht 300
gramm mehl das ist ganz normales
weizenmehl drei eier einen teelöffel
salz drei teelöffel olivenöl und ich
habe jetzt hier noch ein bisschen wasser
es kann nämlich immer sein dass man ein
bisschen wasser hinzufügen muss es kommt
immer auf die eier größe darauf an
und das ist so ein rezept was ihr
einfach auf viele personen auch
hochrechnen könnt denn erzählt pro
person ungefähr 100 gehen
das heißt auf 100 gramm mehl kommt dann
ein 1 esslöffel olivenöl und ebenso ein
bisschen salz ich werde den teig
zubereiten und es geht deswegen für
meiner kitchenaid wenn ihr euren teig
mit der küchenmaschine herstellen wollte
müsste auf jeden fall den knethaken
nehmen ich habe 2001 flach hörer dabei
wäre gerade umziehen und ich alles schon
in kartons habe
und ich finde meinen knethaken nicht
deswegen werde ich jetzt hier anfangen
mit dem nudelteig wert aber dann mit den
händen weiter kneten und zwar gebe ich
jetzt einfach den größten teil des
mähens marl hüls in die schüssel und
wenn ihr in den knethaken habt gibt
einfach alles rein gebe jetzt die einen
so öl und salz und lass das jetzt
einfach kurz verrühren und wird dann das
restliche mehl mit den händen ein kneten
den rest mache ich jetzt mit den händen
mal ist der falsche rührer dafür ist es
gibt einfach mein restliches mehl auf
die arbeitsfläche und gebt da jetzt den
ganzen tag drauf und wenn ihr jetzt
merkt erst zu trocken dann dürft ihr
gerne noch ein bisschen wasser
hinzufügen aber es muss einfach ein
festtag sein also das darf kein weicher
teig sein und dann vertrete ich das
jetzt ganz schnell zu einem glatten
festen teig und am besten immer mit den
ballen hier also nicht mit den fingern
irgendwie da kriegt man gleich krämpfe
und jetzt nehme ich mir einfach etwas
folie und wickelt den teig 1
da könnt ihr natürlich auch gewährt
beutel nehmen und eben immer wieder
verwenden
ich bin ich immer etwas schade gewann
die rohstoffe diesen sachen sport sl
verschwendet ich habe jetzt einfach
leider gab nur folie da ihr könnt auch
ein geschirrtuch anbieten
feuchtes und so las ich den teig jetzt
etwas ruhe und zwar etwa eine halbe
stunde und in der zeit kann ich schon
mal die füllung vorbereiten
und ich habe mir für heute überlegt dass
ich euch heute drei füllungen zeige und
zwar einmal eine hackfleisch füllung des
ist so original schwäbische wie man das
will
und dann habe ich eine vegetarische
füllung eine mit frischkäse und frischen
kräutern die finde ich ganz persönlich
ganz ganz lecker und dann habe ich noch
eine dritte variante des er seine wissel
türkische füllung und zwar ist es eine
kartoffel füllung die habe ich von
meiner guten freundin euro bekommen und
die drei verschiedenen sorten welche
auch verschieden
später füllen und zeige ich dann wie man
die auch verschiedene serviert also sind
in drei verschiedene gerichte eigentlich
heute mache und diesen tag habe ich
jetzt auch dreimal gemacht das heißt die
portionen für die füllungen sind immer
so berechnet dass es für diesen einen
tag reicht also jede füllung reicht für
eine prozent ich werde die füllungen
vorbereiten und zeigt ihr euch jetzt
einfach nacheinander und zeigt dann wie
es weitergeht
jetzt gibt's füllungen nummer eins und
zwar ist es die vegetarische füllung und
dafür braucht ihr diese zu
ihr braucht 250 gramm mascarpone oder
frischkäse ihr könnt auch ricotta nehmen
hauptsache irgendwas cremig ist dann
braucht ihr vier frühlingszwiebeln 80
campana
da nehme ich immer den am stück weil der
einfach viel besser schmeckt und ich
weiß dass es ein echter parmesan ist
etwas pfeffer eine kleine knoblauchzehe
die nämlich anstelle von bärlauch weil
es weil ich jetzt heute kein berlocq
mehr bekommen habe und hier habe ich so
eine 7 kräutermischung und zwar bekommt
man diese mischung so fertig abgepackt
in fast allen supermärkten natürlich
dürft euch aber auch am heimischen
garten bedienen ich habe hier etwas
petersilie sauerampfer schnittlauch
gartenkresse kerbel borretsch pimpinelle
also porridge und kriminelle kannte ich
vorher auch nicht aber in dieser 7
kräutermischung sind die mit dabei und
ich finde die beiden richtig lecker und
das ist jetzt hier auch alles gar kein
hexenwerk ich nehme einfach eine
schüssel und werde jetzt die ganzen
kräuter erst mal klein schneiden und
hier hinein geben
und dann gebt ihr einfach noch die
mascarpone mit dazu oder eben den
frischkäse oder ricotta kinder wird das
ganze mit etwas pech unternehme ich auch
immer ganze pfefferkörner weil es
einfach viel besser schmeckt und der
parmesan geht es einfach noch gerieben
und deswegen brauchen wir auch kein salz
weil nämlich im parmesan genug salz drin
ist und wenn ihr jetzt in kasan ersetzen
wollte ich einen anderen käse müsste auf
jeden fall muss als mit hinzufügen wenn
eben der käse nicht selbst genug salz
hat mit parmesan ist perfekter könnte
aber auch zum feta-käse nehmen und
dächer auf salzig also da dann auch kein
salz hinzufügen aber ich finde so laufen
das wird auch gelassen
kaum der parmesan hier auch mit rein und
das ganze wird einfach so rührt hätte
ich jetzt auch in der kitchen aid machen
können wenn natürlich viel schneller
gegangen
die füllung stelle ich jetzt zur seite
und wird die zweite füllung vorbereiten
jetzt bereite ich füllung nummer zwei
vor das ist die hackfleisch füllung und
dafür braucht ihr diese zutaten und zwar
braucht ihr 250 gramm hackfleisch das
ist jetzt bei mir reines rinder
hackfleisch 150 gramm spinat und zwar
tiefgekühlten spinat und hab ihn
auftauen lassen und ich nehme immer ganz
gerne tiefgekühlten spinat weil der noch
die ganzen vitamine enthält
ich habe hier ein etwas pfeffer einen
teelöffel salz eine zwiebel 1
knoblauchzehe und ein halbes brötchen
bis weiß von gestern
und dieses werde ich gleich in dem
wasser einweichen und ich habe hier noch
etwas frische petersilie
ich werde jetzt meine zwiebel klein
reiben können natürlich auch mit dem
nächsten aber ich habe einfach keinen da
könnte aber auch ganz kleinen würfeln
es geht auf das brauche ich die ganze
haus tricks damit die augen tränen
knoblauch wird auch fein gerieben
daneben die das brötchen und weicht es
in etwas wasser auf einfach damit ein
bisschen weich wird und zerbröselt es
einfach so ein bisschen hier ein
eigentlich nicht zerbröseln sondern
zerdrücken
hier gebe ich jetzt noch das hackfleisch
mit dazu den spinat den drücke ich jetzt
auch ein bisschen aus weil der mehr zu
flüssig ist die flüssigkeit nämlich
nicht das salz
und jetzt nehme ich hier noch ein
bisschen von der petersilie und schneide
die mit rein
und würzt das ganze mit etwas fett war
und wir könnten natürlich auch andere
gewürze benutzen alles was euch gut
schmeckt ich hole jetzt noch ein paar
gewürze
ich gebe es noch ein bisschen curry mit
dazu das ist ein viertel teelöffel etwas
getrockneten oregano und etwas chili
pulver unternehmen jetzt einfach mal so
drei viertel teelöffel nach mitnehmen
ein teelöffel vermögens schafft und dann
wird es jetzt ganz schön miteinander
verrührt und dann ist die füllung nummer
zwei auch schon fertig und jetzt bereite
ich füllung nummer 3 zu und zwar ist es
die kartoffel füllung und das ist eine
türkische füllung und dafür zeige ich
euch jetzt einfach die zutaten
ihr braucht gekochte kartoffeln und zwar
habe ich hier drei stück bzw es waren
drei bevor die auseinander gefallen war
die habe ich jetzt auch schon geschält
und es sind so etwa 400 bis 500 gramm
ihr braucht olivenöl etwas petersilie
eine zwiebel pfeffer salz einen
teelöffel ich habe ja auch noch mal ein
teelöffel chilli ihr könnt auch etwas
weniger nehmen
und ich habe hier getrocknete minze dies
aus dem garten meiner mama system durch
ist die kartoffeln und schreibt sie
einfach in eine große schüssel ihr könnt
sie natürlich auch stampfen aber ich
finde so werden sie einfach seiner und
lockerer schau dir mal dann nehme ich
mir die zwiebel und hacke sie schon frei
zwischenzeit gibt auch schon mal die
petersilie fein gehackt und hab mich
jetzt an den herd gestellt und hier
braucht es olivenöl und hier gebe ich
jetzt einfach ein bisschen olivenöl
reihe sind so vier bis fünf esslöffel
und da gebe ich jetzt die zwiebelwürfel
reihen sieht wirklich super schnell und
lass es einfach mal schön glasig dünsten
und hier gebe ich jetzt das chili pulver
mit rein und welche jetzt noch die
verminderung geben die muss jetzt aber
noch ein bisschen zu erreichen und das
ziel jetzt vom herd runter und geht es
direkt mit zu den kartoffeln
da gebe ich jetzt noch die petersilie
mit dazu und auch das salz und es wird
es schön verrührt füllung nummer drei
ist jetzt auch fertig und ich werde den
teig ausrollen
meine drei führungen sind vorbereitet
und bei jeder dieser maultasche nicht so
dass man den teig ausrollen muss das
werde ich jetzt mit der nudelmaschine
machen ihr könnt es aber auch mit einem
ausruf staat machen und ich zeigte sich
deswegen jetzt nur einmal und später
habe ich sie dann schon vorbereitet ich
werde jetzt mit der frischkäse variante
beginnen und werde jetzt die frischkäse
maultaschen füllen
dafür halte ich mir jetzt meine
nudelteig anfange dann mit der ersten
stufe an und zwar wird da der teig aber
durch gegeben und dann welche immer mal
wieder bemühen damit er einfach nicht an
dem nudel gerät hängen bleibt und werde
ihn jetzt etwa viermal durch lassen so
dass er eben schön dünn ist aber auch
nicht zu dünn
und gerade mit seiner elektrischen
maschine sind die nudel blätter eben
ganz schnell hergestellt und es macht
auch richtig viel spaß
dann werde ich mir diese halbieren weil
sie einfach so zu unhandlich sind ich
schneide mir die ränder weg und
portioniert dann mit hilfe von zwei
teelöffeln einfach so auf dem mound
tauschen so groß wie ich soeben haben
möchte die ränder müsste noch mit wasser
bestreichen damit gleich die zweite
platte schön fest lebt und dann drückt
ihr außen die ränder fest ihnen noch die
markierungen hinsetzen und jetzt könnt
ihr entweder mit einem messer schneiden
oder ihnen einfach so ein ganz
praktisches teig rätseln
das drückt nämlich die ränder fest und
schneidet sie gleichzeitig wenn ihr
sowas nicht abfindet es mit einem messer
machen müsst einmal durchschneiden und
dann aber noch die ränder mit den
fingern oder zum beispiel mit einer
gabel richtig schön verschließen und mit
diesem werkzeug könnte das einfach in
einem schritt machen
zwischen werkzeug aus 100 edelstahl und
es rostet möchte sich total stabil und
gibt es in meinem shop den link dazu
verlinkte ich euch natürlich in der
infobox
es gibt zwar auch geräte von tupperware
und so weiter also machten wir uns drauf
ausrollt aber hier habt ihr einfach den
vorteil des sportplatz und es ist
einfach in jeder größe machbar
die fertigen maultaschen gebe ich dann
auf ein backblech bis ich fertig bin
und so fühle ich jetzt einfach auch die
hackfleisch und die kartoffel
maultaschen
ich habe jetzt alle meine maultaschen
vorbereitet ich habe sie alle in der
gleichen form gemacht um es einfach zeit
zu sparen weil rechteckig sparen einfach
zeit habe jetzt zwei töpfe mit wasser
aufgesetzt aber natürlich braucht er nur
einen topf aber da ich ziehe heute alle
drei sorten habe ich werde jetzt für die
vegetarischen und wir beide vegetarisch
also für die kartoffel und frischkäse
maultaschen werde ich jetzt salzwasser
vorbereiten also zwei liter wasser mit
so eins bis zwei teelöffel ein teelöffel
salz und für die rindfleisch also für
die hackfleisch maultaschen werd ich
etwas gemüsebrühe aufsetzen
die habe ich schon fertig gemacht dass
man selbst gemachte gemüsebrühe und es
sind auch so etwa zwei liter
jetzt gehen wir einfach an den topf ich
beginne jetzt zuerst mit dem frischkäse
gemüse maultaschen und gebt die in mein
kochende salzwasser und wird sie dann
eben kochen lassen in der zwischenzeit
habe ich etwas butter in der pfanne
zerlassen gibt ein paar karotten und
kohlrabi stückchen rein und lasst sie
etwas dünsten und dann gebe ich meine
maultaschen einfach rein und lasst sie
ganz kurz mit schwenken
die zweite variante sie die hackfleisch
maultaschen in der brühe die schmeiße
ich einfach in die kochende brühe und
lasse da eben auch darin garen und ihr
erkennt an ihnen dass sie gas in mitte
an der oberfläche schwimmen und diese
maultaschen bleiben in der brühler also
ich möchte später mit brühe servieren
die dritte variante sind die paar
maultaschen mit kartoffelsalat ich jetzt
erstmal etwas butter in der pfanne gibt
da dann chilipulver mit rein und lasst
es kurz mitdünsten
das da entsteht so ein richtig toller
geschmack und das bindet sich gleich
soeben zur verfeinerung da gebe ich noch
ein bisschen fenster rein dann gebe ich
die maultaschen auch in das kochende
salzwasser und lasse da garen
das dauert so etwa drei bis vier minuten
und wenn sie an der oberfläche schwimmen
dürfte sie hier
ausnehmen diese gebe ich dann in eine
große schale und diese dann die flüssige
butter mit dazu und das hilft dann auch
dass die maultaschen auseinander bleiben
und nicht zusammenkleben
ich hab jetzt alle drei sorten fertig
gekochten sag ich jetzt einfach nicht
servieren
das ist jetzt die vegetarischen mit der
frischkäse füllung und stimmen gemüse
stark gebe jetzt einfach noch ein
bisschen vom sound auf
schnittlauchröllchen und fertig ist
gericht nummer eins die hackfleisch
maultaschen serviert ihr natürlich
direkt mit der kräftigen brühe und
fertig ist gericht nummer zwei
ja
und jetzt kommen meine absoluten
favoriten und zwar sind es die mit der
kartoffel füllung und die schmecken so
lecker mit dieser mutter und dem chili
könnte auch ein ganz normales
paprikapulver nehmen das nicht so schaaf
wird da kommt dann etwas knoblauch
joghurt drauf das ist einfach ein
bisschen naturjoghurt mit knoblauch und
salz vermischt die augen darüber ob das
dann noch mal hier
mit dieser brutto
bin jetzt noch etwas füllung übrig habt
könnt ihr die füllung natürlich aufheben
und einfrieren
die frischkäse füllung können da auf dem
brot streichen die kartoffel füllung
kann man einfach so verlassen und die
hackfleisch führung würde ich am besten
einfach einfrieren wenn ihr jetzt
maultaschen übrig habt ihr einfach nicht
kochen wollte weil ich sie heute nicht
ist könnt ihr sie so mit dem backpapier
zu sammeln einfrieren
und wenn sie dann etwas angefroren sind
könnt ihr sie einfach in der schüssel
oder in andere schüssel übereinander
geben und dann habt ihr die eingefroren
und bei bedarf können dass er einfach in
kochendes wasser oder im ko- runde
früher schmeißen und habt ganz schnell
eure eigenen hausgemachten maultaschen
ich hoffe natürlich dass euch dieses
rezept gefallen hat und diese drei
varianten bestimmt spricht dich eine
davon an ob vegetarier oder doch
fleischesser ich finde alle drei total
lecker nachlesen könnt ihr die genauen
rezepte natürlich auf sell list orten
welt.de und ich würde ich auch gerne mal
demnächst die türkische variante zeigen
also jetzt nicht diese türkischen großen
sondern die original türkischen mantel
sind auch kleine maultaschen und diesen
ganz winzig und die werden ganz anders
hergestellt
falls euch das interessiert zeige ich
euch das ganz gerne mein mann will jetzt
unbedingt dieses pepperoni brot zu essen
ich finde ja maultaschen muss man
alleine essen ohne brot weil er das
schon nudeln sind aber wenn ihr auch
wissen wollt wie ich dieses peperoni
brot gemacht habe oder wie ich mal
andere bootsfahrten machen kann dann
sagt mir bescheid und ich wünsche euch
jetzt auf jeden fall schon mal einen
guten appetit und bis zum nächsten mal
tschüss
okay es geht weiter